Chris I don't know if you've noticed
this but we've changed up the topics for
today because we want to get back to the
Baker Mayfield comments about Daniel
Jones and and I actually have been sent
a chunk of the actual story we talked at
the end of the show about how in the
world Baker Mayfield found himself in a
position to throw shade at Daniel Jones
and what he said about Daniel Jones is I
can't believe the Giants took him and it
blows my mind
some people overthink it that that's
where people go wrong they forget you've
got to win and he also said that
identifying the great characteristics of
a quarterback is a simple process either
you have a history of winning and being
that guy for your team or you don't so
that's his criticism of Daniel Jones but
Chris here's how it's set up
I'm gonna read to you the line before
the first quote from Baker Mayfield
about Daniel Jones this is from whoever
wrote the article near our booth a
Sports Center segment about the New York
Giants catches Mayfield to I and then he
says what he said I mean prime example
Mayfield probably doesn't know this is
the interview yes it sounds like getting
to know each other right right haven't
having a smoothie or a cup of coffee or
you know a ham sandwich and and hey oh
there's aw I can't believe they took
that guy I don't think Baker Mayfield
knew that the recorder was on when he
said what he said III mean I don't think
Jalen Ramsey knew what he said and
thought it was being recorded either
with the GQ you know GQ it sounds like
comes there they spend the day with the
guy and yes guys in the NFL are
accustomed to NFL beat writers and like
that we're yeah at some point you just
sit down and okay let's start the
interview right and it really there's a
little bit of a I don't know a
professionalism or an understanding that
you know before that we might say some
things but that's not the interview I
mean and we're and that's not gonna be
made public this seems like that's never
made clear to where the player has to
say at some point off the record hey
this is off the record right I can't
believe they drafted Daniel Jones you
believe that crap I mean so I am shocked
that Baker Mayfield would say this and
I'm with you I don't think he meant for
it to be said or published publicly I
think this is something he said and
thought he was just making an
observation about sports and he didn't
want to make a make a stink about it but
now it's going to be a stink and
especially with you know Daniel Jones
playing good it's kind of gonna get
thrown back into Baker's face I'm sure
on social media and things today and
this creates a dilemma for me because on
one hand I love the content right I'm
not complaining that we have this thing
that we can talk about but on the other
hand I don't like it I almost feel this
is weird
and I want to make sure articulate
articulate this the right way
i I feel kind of a level of protection
like like don't like hey you non
football reporters don't come make our
players look bad yeah right yeah right
you know what you're doing you're
setting them up for this they're in
their early 20s
they don't understand oh no no Raghu
this is gonna be on the cover of GQ and
I'm gonna be wearing all these clothes
oh wait they're gonna talk to me about
football yeah I'll talk about football
oh wait they're doing this long ass
article when they have all these quotes
where they make me look bad
for saying these things I didn't know
we're part of the interview and you know
at some point I got to put it on the
people around the player to warn them
that this is a trap but I think between
what we've seen without Oh Beckham what
we've seen with Jalen Ramsey and what we
now see with Baker Mayfield somebody got
to be telling these guys you're walking
into a trap and it kind of pisses me off
that that these non football writers can
Barnstorm in and draw all this stuff out
of guys because they don't have to deal
with them again right it would be you
know if you never have to deal with that
guy again you can chew him up and spit
him out and make him look bad nothing
I'm saying you should do that but I
think they have that benefit where they
can worry about making the best story
possible those compelling quotes because
they don't have to have an ongoing
relationship with those teams and with
those players and there's lines you
don't cross and I think you're crossing
the line when you take those casual
comments and use those against the
players in the body of the story yeah it
is it's a little below the belt that way
I agree with you the player is not
expecting that he's not it's just
against the kind of the unwritten rules
of the situation and out of the fact
that more times are not with these type
of stories - they're not they don't go
through the team right
so nobody they're from the team is there
to kind of watch over the proceedings to
go hey he's not gonna answer that or to
butt in when Baker
Mayfield does say that he said hey that
was off the record right you know that
right there was none of that that's what
happens when you go through you know
guys personal handlers or you know his
group around them the managers whatever
it may be this is the fine line you
dance with and yet now Baker he's gonna
have to deal with some of these
questions this week and and I don't know
whether or not Baker Mayfield has a
different marketing agent than football
agent but the football agent would be
more likely to say whoa no you got to be
careful with this
I think the marketing agent isn't
viewing it through that same prism the
marketing agents agenda is to make the
guy as big as possible
this makes the guy as big as possible
and even if you have to deal with a
little complication from time to time
because the guy said something
unfortunate you know what he still said
something that people are talking about
so you get a lot of weird relationships
you get some conflicts of interest and
ultimately you get guys smitten by the
prospect of being on the cover of GQ
yeah and you know the photo spread and
everything that goes along with it and
and I think they do let their guard down
because they don't think of it as
traditional sports media but every year
they get somebody and every year it
gives us something to talk about so I
hate you q we don't mean anything by it
I mean I guess you know we appreciate
the fact that you're giving us something
to talk about we just don't like what
you're doing to the NFL players because
it does feel a little underhanded yeah
we'd like GQ and their writers to be a
little more transparent and to go okay
we're starting the interview or before
before the day even begins
announce it hey everything from here on
out hey nice to meet you Baker
everything from here on out is on the
record and part of the article yeah you
gotta make that some sort of statement
or the player is gonna feel you know
below the belt shot low-balled whatever
it may be and you know you made the
point these are young guys who you know
we all think of them all they're making
money and they play football so they're
mature and they have all you know life's
answers already at this point no no
Baker Mayfield still a young man who's
learning a lot on the fly and having a
whole world thrusted upon him that he's
never experienced before I mean even
being the Heisman winner at Oklahoma it
ain't like this and ain't like me in the
quarterback of the in the NFL for the
Cleveland Browns they
weren't GQ wasn't coming to Oklahoma to
talk to him I can promise you that it's
a different stratosphere and yeah it is
kind of a cheap shot that seems like or
at least how GQ is handling this and
maybe not letting that be known all
right we got more things we could talk
about today but I'll tell you what this
is enough time for PFT ot we want to
avoid PFT ot ot we got plenty more
things to get to as the preseason
continues to unfold Cris sources close
to me telling me that you're actually
off tomorrow but you'll be back Thursday
and Friday I kind of like the Chris Sims
on Friday approach although I know that
hey that's like a religious thing for
you you can only have your four days per
week but you know hey whatever we got to
do for big cat I mean he's a big deal so
I got a reschedule my whole schedule cuz
a big cat damn guy I mean gosh I don't
know what he's got going on but geez I'm
doing it for him all right well what big
cat tomorrow though he doesn't do PFT ot
oh he doesn't know damn I shouldn't have
said that because now you're gonna try
to no yep I'm not doing it Friday the
hell with you anybody have a great day
it was fun today everybody check us out
at Pro Football Talk comm new Chris Sims
on button coming later today a PFT p.m.
with a Drew Brees interview and plenty
more Pro Football Talk comm all day long
see you Wednesday see ya
[Music]
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports